vegetarier stern das ist der name die
supermassereichen schwarzen loch im
zentrum der milchstraße genau dort hat
jetzt ein astronomie team aus den usa
eine bisher unbekannte struktur entdeckt
eine rotierende scheibe aus eher kühlem
wasserstoffgas diese umgibt das schwarze
loch im abstand von nur einem
hundertsten lichtjahr zudem verhält sich
diese gas scheibe äußerst merkwürdig
ihre lage im raum hat keiner so erwartet
klicks um science-fiction den gibt es
täglich faszinierendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen in der mitte
der wild straße befindet sich ein
massemonster dass eine 4 millionenfach
größere masse hat als die sonne und
diese masse ist auf engstem raum
zusammen gepackt ein schwarzes loch also
sein name sagt gitarrist stern nur 26
tausend lichtjahre ist es von uns
entfernt bislang gelang es aber
lediglich heiße gase und magnetfelder in
der nähe seines erhaltenes horizonts zu
beobachten fachleute gehen zudem davon
aus dass dieses massemonster über einen
strahlend jet verfügt und zudem wird
vermutet dass sich jenseits der
millionen grad heißen gase am schwarzen
loch vergleichsweise kühles
wasserstoffgas befindet doch dieses nur
etwa 10.000 grad heiße gas ist nicht so
leicht aufzuspüren denn im gegensatz zu
dem extrem heißen gas sendet es keine
energie in form von starker
röntgenstrahlung aus dennoch gelang es
jetzt eine us forschungsteam diesem
wasserstoffgas auf die schliche zu
kommen und zwar durch verräterische
spektrallinien diese entstehen weil die
wasserstoff atome durch die benachbarte
intensive strahlung immunisiert werden
durch vereinigung mit ihrem elektronen
werden sie dann wieder zu neutralem atom
so entsteht eine charakteristische linie
im wasserstoff spektrum und genau diese
spur konnte das us army team mit dem
atacama large millimeter submillimeter
array alma beobachten
so wird die verteilung des kühlen
wasserstoff gases um das schwarze loch
herum also sichtbar
es handelt sich um eine scheibe die
durch das gas gebildet wird und die das
schwarze loch umgibt und zwar in der
tausendfachen entfernung der erde zur
sonne in zahlen ausgedrückt bedeutet das
einen abstand von nur einem 100
lichtjahre etwa ein zehntel der
jupitermassen
die masse dieser glasscheibe dazu elena
kohutikova die an der studie beteiligt
war
wir sind die ersten die diese scheibe
abbilden und seine rotation ermitteln
doch die neu entdeckte glasscheibe
verhält sich anders als es das
astronomenteam vermutet habe dazu heißt
es in der studie
die ausrichtung des wasserstoff frings
stimmt mit keiner der anderen strukturen
im galaktischen zentrum über ein
konkret ist sie gegenüber dem orbit des
nahegelegenen sterns g2 um 90 grad
gekippt und steht zudem quer zur ebene
der milchstraße gemeinsam hat sie
lediglich ihre rotation mit anderen
sterne und galaxien in ihrer nähe
dennoch sind noch viele fragen offen
beispielsweise rätseln fachleute
weiterhin über das verhalten und die
struktur der glasscheibe ist der
wasserstoff gleichmäßig verteilt oder
handelt es sich um dichterin gaskunden
die sich angesammelt haben und die
scheibe bilden klar ist nur dass das gas
im schnitt eine dichte von 100.000 bis
einer million wasserstoffteilchen pro
kubikzentimeter aufweist das hatten die
aktuellen messungen des us
forschungsteams ergeben aber auch eine
andere sache soll durch weitere
beobachtungen mit alma und weiteren
zukünftigen weltraumteleskopen geklärt
werden dazu elena musik offer noch haben
wir kein genaues bild davon wie die
aggression an einem solchen schwarzen
loch abläuft vor allem also die
wechselwirkung zwischen dem heißen gas
am ereignishorizont von sagittarius
stern und dem kühlen wasserstoffgas
interessiert die experten und
expertinnen besonders schwarze löcher
könnten leben ermöglichen ein video von
raum zeit lockt der zukunft anklicken
anschauen und natürlich raumzeit
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran